俺の名前は天才小学生。[笑い]
ラーメンとメンマとライス。
あんたはメンマーライスよ。
はあ。
ラーメンとメンバーマーライス。
いただきます。
うん。やみ。
パー。うますぎて神。師匠、母弟にしてください。
子供がラーメン作るのなんて無理。無理。
豚骨と柄の背後は7対3。スープの温度は
92.4°。なんで分かった?
だって僕天才ですから。
おしれえ。
師匠、準備万です。早速ラーメンを。
まずは湯りの練習。1日1万回れ
は?はい。ほらやるちゃんよ。遊ぼうわよ。
食べる食べる。
はい。じゃあ今からトラ授業を始めます。誰す授業中に何してんだ?
湯りの棺は麺から必要な成分まで飛ばしてしまう。
[音楽]
絶妙な水分量を見極めるんだ。ほわふわしてて。気持ち。
湯ぎりは完璧だら次はスープだ。
俺を感動させられるようなスープを作ってみろ。
はい。
スープは理論だ。必ず正解の配合が存在する。最短ルートで最高のスープを作り上げる。
[音楽]
できた。
うん。うまいな。
だって僕天才で
うまいだけじゃだめだ。
やり直し。何が足りないんだろう。
何な?今日は何してたの?
スープちゃん。はい。
何が好き?
何してんだ?
ちょっと暑ぎ。じゃあそこをかき混ぜるね。これで調整しますからね。ま、
師匠は常にスープの状態を気にしながら愛を持って作ってるんだ。
混ぜ混ぜ混ぜ混ぜ。うん。美いしい。
俺に足りなかったのはスープへの愛だ。
スープちゃん。はい。何が好き?おいち。おいち。
待って待せ混ぜ混ぜ。
さすがに体力の限界だ。どれどれ。と骨は
うますぎ。
このスープにはお前の愛を感じ。てことは
合格だ。自分の店持っていいぞ。
やった。
こうして俺はラーメン豚をオープンした。よし。あ、腹た。助け
いらっしゃいませ。子供ラーメン
1つはよ。
お待たせしました。豚ラーメンです。初詮子供が作ったラーメンだろ。なんだこれ?うめえ。
今日から毎日通ります。ありがとうございます。うまいよ。
ここが新しくできた店か。
俺は新しくできた店を潰すのが趣味なんだ。豚ラーメ
[音楽]
お待たせしました。
あれ髪の毛入ってるんだけど。
そ、すみません。
こんな声食えねえよ。う、きったね。やだ、やだ。はい。
こ援助上確定。警察呼びましょうか?
[笑い]
いや、大丈夫です。
おい、おい、おい。次はラーメ腕ですか?こりゃまずいね。あ、やばい。で、やっちゃったね、今回はえ、
てめえここのラーメン一口でも食ったことあんのか?
あるわけねえだろ。うわあ。
おい、おい、おい、おい、おい、おい、おい、おい。うますぎんだろ。すいませんでした。
いいよ。その代わりこの動画SNS
にあげるね。
はい。何でも押してください。それでは時に参ります。うま。うま。最高。最高。迷惑客は逆に利用するんだ。
その後この迷惑客の動画は日本中でバズり歌の名前は全国にしろ当たった。
ラーメン豚
オープンです。
豚ラーメン1つ
お待たせしました。
うまい棒ください。こちらお好きなうまい棒をお選びください。
明太子でこちらうまいめになります。おいしい。
[音楽]
天才チーブダン1つ
お待たせしました。ふ、うすぎ。
屋根ください。ニンニク入れますか?ニンニク野菜ましまし。マジで。
お待たせしました。
ニンニク屋シましましのマシです。
まるでマックとジャメの木なんよ。
カップ麺1
つください。お待たせしました。あ、うまさ
何食べてるんですか?
豚ってとこのカップ麺だ。お前も食うか?
ああ、わからん、うわからん。
あうわからどうしどうしどうした?タ
パした。
うがる。
美いしい。
うめえ。
これ何?
バンカラジオのライブイベントが来年の
1月10日にあるからみんな来てね。
ありがとうございました。
ご褒美のカップ麺ンタイム。うん。辛さが足りないわね。私がラーメン屋をしてもっと美味しいラーメン作るわ。
はラーメンに人生を捧げるわ。めちゃくちゃのこと言うなよ。
あんたかっこいいってさ。よいしょ。よいしょ。
ラーメン豚コープンです。
おら。らけら。
骸骨ラーメン1つ。
ガしこまり。
おお。なれ。美いしくなれ。お待たしました。骸骨ラーメンです。うわ、なんだこれ?まずすぎる。
[音楽]
残したら罰金
100万円だからね。
だったら食ってやるよ。
やっぱ無理。ああ、
万円だわ。無理。無理、無理、無理、無理。
スペシャルラーメンください。
お待たせしました。金骨流麺です。
ほら避け。ほら。うあ
よ。筋肉片固め。顔男。いやあ、こんな豚骨ラーメン食えねえよ。
ほら食べなさいよ。ポンコツイケメンちゃん。ほら。はい。ああ。
あ。う。
カぶのカバから。
まず
ゲロないよ。
マイナス200万なさいよ。あ、
[笑い]
お母さんはお金儲設ためにラーメン屋を経営して僕の店を乗ったんです。ラーメンはお金稼ぎの道具なんかじゃない。
俺がたっぷり説教る
師匠。ええ。えーええドル。
ラーメンより金を優先しやがって。この下蔵バ塩に傷口をするな。
やす、3
人で協力し店をやることになった。
なんで?
その後僕たちのラーメン屋はまた琢に繁盛した。
ファイヤーラーメンです。
おおしかった。ありがとございました。ありがと。
[笑い]
ありがとうございました。
ちょ、今日の売上売上に。
おい、店の売上がるな。
金のためにラーメンを作ってるなら俺は協力できねえ。私を笑わしたら
1万円あげるわ。
めちゃくちゃ顔で大爆笑してる人やりまあげる。
[笑い]
ありがとうございます。え、きこさん一生ついてきます。ありがとうございます。
じゃあやちゃん、あとは適当にやっといて。
きこさん、待って待って。
結局金かよ。
お前のじゃないだ。あさ何やってんだよ。おい、あか聞いてんのか?おい、
[笑い]
アクション。
うわ、なんだこれ?まずるいらねえ
[笑い]
いらないらない。もう押してんだから。
ワンピースのキャラで
番波が好きなんだなあ。ちょ、すっちゃいました。
[笑い]
それさ、ダってまず何?官バカ野郎のダ知らないし。小学生わかんないよな。
のがつまんなかったけど状況が面白かったから状況に笑った。
いやいやいや小学生向けは難しいよ。
いやいや。y